you're welcome you to this video
Grand Master airing lowborn yeah Burt so
what is he doing would India at one of
his pet openings that he plays quite
frequently now it has to up the moolaade
am now I said I really hate to allow b5
in this position
castles was too quickly usually here
just castles himself okay okay it's so
kind of okay with it's not ideal
[Music]
I try to bring the bishop around
tranform 95 okay that looks quite
reasonable for white I mean I mean like
black seems okay avid and still quite
happy after I screwed up the move order
a might click on this 7 anyway so let's
go get this that get let's get this done
let's say
I can fly to the ending here with the
two modes seems perfectly okay
okay what is my plan and disposition
probably improving this night night -
III maybe looking at the square maybe
yes we tough to do much here seems like
he wants to play a fun item okay I think
I'm going for Quincy three it's
difficult to do much share with Queens
on the board
check-check
and he wants to play a form but maybe
this is better okay I wonder if f1 is
useful here or not probably yes please I
think a6 is potentially something that I
can maybe attack okay so here Knight b6
or 93 I think this is better
94 not really getting anywhere
[Music]
hmm yeah I cannot do much I cannot take
the pawn here in any way okay I'll just
stay don't really see an idea and I can
try this which is probably nothing but
should be three step step possible okay
okay now I can take these six okay so
put some pressure on e5 which should do
all that much okay that was not so good
black resign now I was just I think that
was just completely for the whole game
almost just died I mean I played in a
somewhat passive way that I didn't
really see much active that I could do I
mean I would have liked to but I didn't
see anything no I could have taken on b5
here don't even understand that move why
does Cedric
okay yeah because he has this one okay I
had the tricky tactic it's really tricky
okay so there was a chance there with
him and I said I think this was like
completely equal yeah
now Andrew basically check you will not
be six here
yeah was just winning the pawn oh my god
hmm okay okay I didn't look look hard
enough
yeah yeah it's a boy when he had learned
at the bishop so I had one or two
chances actually in this game okay guys
thanks for watching